em um vídeo de uma pessoa vão construir
uns tênis que saltam usando umas boas
não construir isso tudo aqui em casa eu
vou tentar colar os móveis e os tênis
vou tentar que o salto e vou tentar
fazer um turismo feito com podem ser
pessoais para superar tantas vezes não
viria tão a fim de você he's funny nós
aqui no canal inscrevam se deixem muito
mais que também que embora lá pra ver o
lado pessoal de quem fala andar que
sejam muito bem vindos a bola e hoje vou
tentar construir um brinquedo novo é
porque já o fato de os brinquedos vão
dar o seu jogo você brincar com isto eu
preciso mexer no olho no outro dia olhei
pro money de mim o campeonato diferente
apenas o colega loja online e como
estava a dizer um outro de olhar para o
meu boné e eu vi que o logo do jogo o
salto muito alto e ii e eu pensei eu
quero saltar tanto como eu mas não sei
como eu tive que pesquisar pela internet
e encontrei um mecanismo que faz saltar
assim atual acho que quebrou o champix é
uma coisa sem isso é que vocês vão ver
este mas esta coisa louca custa entre
100 e 400 bola eo novo comprar e agora
para além de secar demora a chegar aqui
em portugal então não foi o menor estava
e eu pensei pessoal eu posso sim e isso
voto cientista pensou no menino não
pensei nada agora pensa em jogar a
pensar como é que eu vou poder ir méxico
já que alguma criança tem gente tenha a
bola eu pensei em colocar um volume
extremamente eu não sei se o resultado
mas sem colocar vários módulos meus
tênis talvez um salto não sai então é
isso que nós vamos testar o uso pessoal
e desde já que não tem embaixo vai
voltar ou não executa esta que não
resulta mas não sei que vai voltar
porque essa gente está
e não só a primeira coisa que vou ter
que fazer eu vou desenhar a sola do meu
tênis nesta placa de madeira eo elenco
tem ainda nome sol
[Música]
o projeto atende king da exata e agora é
só cortar
agora é muito fácil é sobre todos os
buracos na sol e para isso eu comprei
uma lâmina de boquim que é exatamente o
mesmo vida e os nossos maior para isso
encaixa perfeitamente para lá então só
vamos abrir os buracos prático e rápido
o espanhol enfrentou e não te esqueças
do piloto
[Música]
a aae pessoal está a evoluir bem agora é
só para o pará não eu não sei se vocês
querem fazer isso em casa vão fazer em
casa mas foi fazer compras cola mais
forte que vocês encontrarem por exemplo
foi hoje publicou mais forte que o
previsto e foi engolido uma coisa assim
eu estava com do euro levou a que os
mesmos declarou ontem que um dinossauro
e direct connect
[Música]
ok pessoal agora é só deixar ficar e
agora conta com você que eu acho que
vamos sair porque na hora e psol já
sabem deixe muito aqui no espírito ele
está a dar muito trabalho e eu acho que
por isso ele não quiser deixar lá e
também para não deixar é claro mas não
importa importa 15 código já se vocês
não deixassem lá que neste dia vocês vão
ter 100 anos de sarney é um homem que eu
também sou magro não se pára está muito
duro será a a quem esta forte realmente
qual não é então temos as nossas solas
coladas o próximo passo a tomar meus
móveis a nossa só quatro ou cinco em
cada sol
[Música]
na incrível mas não só como ficou em
locais ok ok ok
foi muito constrangedor agora aqui um
ponto importante é que eu não quero
estragar o tenente então eu acho que vou
optar pela solução mais simples que seja
importante é que embora lá está
espero que eu consiga levantar daqui
depois de colocar o seu padrinho efe
nomes leite
o pessoal já tem isso nos pés mas eu não
consigo andar só vamos ver se consigo
voltar com espécies para lá que vai ser
difícil o primeiro pé no chão funciona
só consiga votar só documentos altar
enquanto que enrico feitosa cento disse
o bispo mas vamos tentar ir com calma
agora garante estar pronto a saltar mais
alto
a espanha é o do seu perdão
aconteceu o que eu mais temia exijo nem
preciso dizer agora no hospital eu vou
morrer eu vou entrar em coma
não eu acho que faltou ao treino o
trailer consistência à assistência à
criança lúcia
o estudo agora mais tranqüilo não só
como vocês puderam ver da popular sim só
tem mais alto sim nem que seja concedido
não só como é que vocês acham que
resultou o que não resultou andar assim
e só assim só que de maneira individual
[Música]
e não só para ter um estado de espírito
nem que eu tentei construir em casa
falhou sim deu errado deu resultou claro
para nós aqui no canal inscrevam e achei
muito a equipe e é isso fique bem até
aproximaram